um you know it's actually an interesting
concept i've been thinking about this
um a little bit more lately whether it's
um becoming famous or
um uh something like that like you can't
because people say to me sometimes
they'll be like oh aren't you famous i'm
like i don't
i think it i don't i don't think it
works like that like i'm not i don't
just become famous or i'm not famous i'm
only famous if you think i'm famous
so it's like maybe legend is similar in
a sense that you don't sign up you can't
go
sign up to be a legend like you can
become a singer you can become a race
car driver you can't become
famous or you can't become a legend that
has to be in the eye
of the beholder
yeah i mean and yeah
absolutely i'm sure that you know
anybody who's a public figure has had
that experience of
in one set of circumstances
you know you're incredibly you know you
go you walk into one room or a bar
or a restaurant and everybody in that
bar and restaurant or party knows who
you are
and then you walk next door and no one
knows who you are
and it's actually like the first few
times that happens it can be quite
humbling but it's really healthy
just to remember like the majority of
the people on the planet kind of largely
have no idea who we are
which is which is exactly how it should
be um
you know i think like because i when i i
don't know
what your experience was like when i
first started becoming a public figure
to my great shame i sort of succumbed
to the narcissism and the
self-involvement that comes along with
that
you know where you where for a while i'm
ashamed to say i expected people to sort
of
know who i was and to treat me
differently and that
it's just not a it's not a healthy way
to live i mean we look at our culture
and there's so many public figures
who are sort of destroyed by being
public figures
you know it's it's very i mean it's not
just confusing it sometimes it brings
out the worst parts of our personalities
so
i am glad that i
personally have sort of gone past that
we're like you know like
i guess i'm still a public figure but
it's not necessarily how
i think of myself on a day-to-day basis
yeah
yeah you mean you're not passing by the
mirror going
hey legend hey famous guy hey superstar
no i walk by the mirror and i'm like who
invited the old guy into my house
don't worry as we all age we're all
thinking they're like whoa where'd that
wrinkle come from
i will tell you that i see you as a
legend you can only speak from your
experience but
what was it that led you down that sort
of
path where you're like you expected
people to know who you are you expected
certain things
have you realized what it was or was it
more a matter of just
sort of alchemizing that and processing
and
and and and shifting it well i mean when
i first started making music i never
expected to have a career
as a musician you know when i was
you know in my teens in junior high
school in high school i played in little
punk rock bands
and like a good night for us was playing
to 10 people
playing to 15 people you know the first
single i ever released with my punk rock
band in connecticut
we sold 100 copies and we thought
we thought that was pretty great that
meant a hundred people had gone out of
their way to buy our record and i was
like wow
this is this is the pinnacle like it's
not going to get any better than this
so when in the 90s when i started having
more
sort of broader success it was so
unexpected and it just it
played to all of my and maybe this is
very very obvious but it played to all
of my
insecurities it played to my my
feel my lack of self-worth my
feelings of inadequacy and somehow i
felt that you know if
people were nice to me you know if
people wanted to date me if people
invited me to their parties
it sort of gave me this external
sort of validation and as is often the
case i became
way too attached to it you know because
you know i had grown up you know my mom
and i were on food stamps and welfare i
was you know
a little insecure kid growing up and
then suddenly when you're on the
receiving end of attention
you know especially glamorous attention
it can be
really corrupting you know it's because
it's
so it's so attractive um
[Music]
you know i feel like for myself and just
the things that i've gone through in
life and especially over the last
year like i've realized just how much
like our parents and childhood has
i mean it's it's really the root of
everything there's it's like
the most complicated giant
box that lives underground in the
subconscious
and just wreaks havoc through patterns
until you recognize it
yeah and it's hard because the patterns
you know who we are and who we were
how we were formed as children
you know rarely are we capable of even
recognizing those patterns because
they're so familiar and it's only
you know like we become adults and we
start
almost like encountering the
consequences of those
patterns you know whether it's in
relationships whether it's with
addiction whether it's with friends what
have you
and then suddenly you know whether it's
through therapy whether it's
through self-help sobriety what have you
you know like hopefully we learn enough
about ourselves to sort of
at least identify those old patterns
and work to move past them in so far as
we can you know it's certainly
obviously much easier said than done if
it was
easy we would all be healed and it would
be one quick moment and we'd be like oh
yes
yeah i i i forgive you mom i forgive you
dad
but it's not it's not that easy because
like you said they're just like they're
patterns they're
they're ingrained in us and they're
they're almost like invisible because
there's such patterns
and um yeah i mean life is just such a
journey
i mean such a such a complicated
journey i i it's not and one thing i've
one thing i've been sort of hopefully
learning lately
and i don't know why this is the most
self-evident thing i could ever say
is realizing that it's a complicated
journey
for everyone you know because when i was
growing up i thought like i was the only
confused person i was the only scared
person i was the only insecure person
you know i was the only person who
really was filled with doubts
and then time passes you realize oh
everybody is you know it's just
unfortunately we live in a culture
where most of us are really good at
pretending otherwise
you know people pretending they're
smarter than they actually are
cooler than they actually are um sexier
than they actually are like
so it is sort of nice remembering that
every human being on the planet
regardless of
you know how they were born where they
were born like
everybody has their own experience of
the human condition and it's
it's confusing to everybody like was
there a moment where you realize that
that you like finally
like freed yourself from this
self-inflicted burden that you're alone
um
oddly i did i was driving and it
it came just a few years ago you know
the actual for like the
physical realization of this i was
driving from los angeles
down to palm springs um i was playing
coachella and i was driving on the 10
and i'm sure you've spent some time on
the 10. you know and the 10
between los angeles and
palm springs is gross like it's just
especially like when it's hot and
there's traffic like
it's just it's awful and i was you know
sitting in my car
you know feeling sorry for myself
because the traffic
was terrible and i was you know like
everything outside was ugly and brown
and then i looked around at everybody
else in traffic and i had this
realization i was like oh everyone hates
this
like it's not just me in fact most
people probably hate it
way more than i do because you know like
i was leaving my nice home
to go play at a festival and i was going
to stand on stage in front of 40 or 50
000 people like that's
i'm not looking it's clearly like my
circumstances were different than most
other people's and realizing like okay
if this is unpleasant for me like i'm in
my nice car the air conditioning is
going i'm listening to music
and i am happy just think
how much less happy the people around me
are and it gave me this sense
of just very simple
you know and i hope this doesn't sound
insincere but really
simple compassion just this realization
like these
you know everybody is struggling i
certainly
can't take my problems
too seriously you know especially when
people are dealing with problems that
are so much worse and more serious than
mine